you know in some respects I look at what
you do and uh compare it to like hip-hop
Like Rappers just being like you know
extravagant crazy you know like when uh
when everybody was like oh we we got you
like you didn't know in that house you
were renting it like to me I'm like that
makes perfect [__] sense you know
I've rented every [__] house I've
ever had nowhere I've never I've never
owned a piece of real estate in
California in my life I never want to be
a resident
um
part of it was taxes part of his laws um
part of it was I just like didn't want
to [__] sink that much Dell in you
know and so it was one of those things
we I actually paid 5 million for the
option to buy that house and the plan
was to buy that house but not to like
keep it to flip it because I thought you
know we actually got a strike price I
think it was like 60 million for that
house it was listed for like 90. and I
figured you know we could make this the
new [__] Playboy Mansion but cooler
whatever and if you remember the Playboy
Mansion sold for like 100 120 million it
was a [__] yeah it was a house that
like you literally it's a tear down you
know I'm pretty sure I was banned from
it but
they didn't like that they didn't take
kindly to me uh blatantly doing cooking
right out in the open like you're not
supposed you're supposed to have a
little bit of discretion yeah yeah I
remember I went there and it was like
always like a child that dreamed to go
there but I didn't go till it was like
later when they were kind of like
selling the tickets for like the karma
thing or whatever and it was cool but it
wasn't like
back in the day you know yeah I bet I
bet
um what's the coolest party you've ever
been to that comes to mind I mean
definitely the ones I threw right I mean
I threw some [__] monsters I mean
they were like I had cardi B performing
in my living room like it was I mean we
had 3 000 girls and like maybe 300 guys
you know I remember one time
I had invited like some veterans out and
there was like because I told these
girls like look if you don't want to
shuttle you've got to show up early so
there's I think it was like 18 or 1900
girls in lingerie running around the
house and there was like me and like I
don't know it's like six amputee
veterans or something yeah it was just
like nothing but [__] [__]
everywhere
um and so like I just always knew like
when you started a party like that like
with that ratio like the power could go
out you could run out of liquor it's
like there's no way the party's not
going to be good the [__] singer
could not show up but if you got all the
hot [__] I mean that's where guys go to
the club we don't go there dance we're
not going there to [__] Bob her head
we could drink in our [__] you know
goddamn closet with our buddies of All
We Care like we're going to the club to
get [__] that's like that's one of the
things that I think a lot of people
don't realize like the only reason guys
go to Club is get laid we're not going
there talk to our friends because why
the [__] do you want to like scream at
your buddy can't [__] hear anything
like nobody goes there other than to get
a [__] like these girls go there to
dance maybe but like the guys is to get
laid so if you want to throw a good
party you have a bunch of [__] hot
girls and you have the ratio right and I
realize that like you know when you have
the ratio right the girls have to come
to you this is a very different Dynamic
and so that's what I always want to
create you know and I said I did it like
on a smaller scale
when I was living at Blue Jay
um it's like Richard Gere's old house
and um
had like 300 girls you know 30 guys and
would do these like pool parties and
[__] man the girls got aggressive
because nobody's paying attention to
them so they're like coming to you you
know yeah and it's a very different
Dynamic when that's happening you know
how do you get 300 girls are you like
emptying out a model agency into your
house promoters modeling agencies and
then I was also throwing poker games so
I was like hiring a lot of these girls
to like do the poker stuff and these
girls are making three three to five
thousand dollars a night you know this
is a very like coveted gig and um
I wasn't paying them [__] we I actually
made money off of them so we would split
the tips 50 50. so it was like I I
offered them
I'd either pay him 100 an hour or we can
split the tips and what I found was like
unequivocally
the girls that split the tips would
[__] you know make a killing because
they cared and the girls you paid hourly
were like you know usually they would
make more than you paid them but they
weren't as motivated so then we just
went straight to like splitting the tips
but like I said they're making so much
[__] money like the smallest chip we
had on the table was I think like 500
chips so like
the men on these girls are getting
tipped is 500 bucks to get a drink to
[__] you know rub somebody's back
it's like you know and then these guys
are winning you know half million dollar
pots and it's like you know they feel
cheap throwing them anything other than
five thousand so it's like one of these
like weird scenarios where these girls
would make crazy bread and um and yeah
then they would bring their friends and
it was this whole thing so like I mean
what the [__] are you gonna do if you're
a model like go [__] bust your ass
wear 30 outfits and shoot for [__]
you know 400 bucks or you're gonna go
like work a poker game for four hours
and make five thousand you know so it's
like one of those things where I was
like this is before like the sugar daddy
crazes before like you know only fans
before like the whole ecosystem got
ruined you know until like back when
like 5000 was a lot of [__] money
these girls now it's like you know [__]
like the whole thing's crazy and turned
on its head but like back then it was a
big [__] deal you know and so they
were like really fighting to work these
games how do I you're asking about 300
girls how do you get three girls to my
house you know like I'm trying to figure
that out well like I said the poke thing
was like a big thing and so and here's
another thing with the poker thing is
like so girls started realizing like hey
we can invite other girls and take 20 of
their money so like if one girl invites
five girls and she's getting 20 of you
know what these girls are making she's
making the same amount but she doesn't
have to work right so then you know they
they send over you know tons of girls so
I had like this pipeline of like
constant like new chicks and when they
would like come over to like interview
for these games I mean it was like
literally like you know these chicks
like thought it was like the casting
couch and I'm like you know I'm like
this is a [__] business you know what
I mean like I got tons of [__] I'm not
like worried about getting my dick
sucked in the bathroom here but these
chicks are like I mean these chicks are
like ready to do it all you know and I
was it was one of those things where
um you know we would play poker like big
enough Stakes so the guys didn't really
give a [__] about the girls but you
wanted to have the hot girls there
anyways but the focus was on the poker
like we're playing for crazy money so
like
I think the smaller games kind of got
the reputation of where the girls were
getting paid to [__] and like they're
doing drugs and people are drinking and
[__] but like at my games nobody's
getting [__] up it was like serious
you know they were like everybody's out
for blood they're [__] hot you know
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude